no
[Música]
al gobierno
qué mal está nuestra sociedad
qué mal
trabajo tengo
no nos hemos puesto a pensar cada uno de
nosotros que el que está mal aquí soy yo
que el que está mal aquí eres tú
que nosotros somos los que vamos a
formar el futuro de este país de nuestra
familia de nuestras casas
cuando me enteré que te venía a pachuca
a mi ciudad
a donde me siento orgulloso yo de ser
y que tengo que estar ahí y me lo puse
de objetivo
y aquí estoy hoy con ustedes
los objetivos que planteamos en nuestra
vida debemos de trabajar para alcanzar
los los objetivos sólo sirven para dos
cosas para superarlos y para ponernos un
nuevo objetivo
yo he trabajado mucho a lo largo de los
años a lo largo de mi vida de mi corta
vida voy a cumplir 30 años
he definido
que voy a luchar
por una mejor ciudad por un mejor estado
y contribuir a la medida de lo posible
para tener un mejor país
he tomado esta decisión
y con tres pilares que considero
son muy importantes y fundamentales en
mi vida
es como he decidido hacer esa ruta el
trabajo
tengo un mentor en lo personal tengo una
persona muy cercana mi papá
a quien yo le reconozco sus logros
personales familiares laborales
profesionales y él me ha dicho muchas no
sé cuántas porque en verdad muchas veces
algo muy importante el 51% de que te
vaya bien en tu trabajo en tu familia en
lo que hagas profesionalmente te tiene
que gustar
te tiene que gustar con eso ya vas
ganando ya tienes el 51%
el otro 49% va a depender de tu talento
de tus condiciones por qué no decirlo
pero el 51% depende de que te guste
les voy a platicar algo que me pasó en
mi empresa uno de mis compañeros de
trabajo un colaborador que está con
nosotros me dice el licenciado yo quiero
ser el gerente de la sucursal
dije pues trabajada vamos vamos a
trabajar vamos a crear ese futuro para
que le eches ganas y el día de mañana
estés donde quieres estar pero por
curiosidad por qué quieres estar ahí
porque quieres estar allí porque tanta
insistencia que quiere ser el gerente
es que quiero trabajar menos
bueno definitivamente esa persona era un
excelente colaborador era un gran
trabajador
pero
no estaba contento con lo que estaba
haciendo tenía el 49% lo tenía le
faltaba enamorarse de su trabajo que le
gustará lo que estaba haciendo
pues bueno definitivamente esa persona
no fue el gerente de la sucursal
cuando yo hablo del trabajo
que nos enamoremos de nuestro trabajo
que nos guste
pues hay que trabajarlo hay que
esforzarnos no basta con querer ser el
empleado del mes no basta con quererlo
hay que hacer un sacrificio hay que
despertarse temprano hay que dar ese
extra
dejemos de pensar que ponerle el pie al
de al lado nos va a hacer crecer como
personas eso nos entierra como seres
humanos hay que ser mejores personas
todos si queremos la posición de mi jefe
hay que hacer que mi jefe sea el jefe y
crezcamos juntos hay que ser mejores
personas
participación
el segundo de mis pilares
en esta etapa de mi vida creo que ese es
la etapa más importante
hay ocasiones que me han dicho es que
estás joven espérate no participes estás
muy joven
entonces que me toque esperar
no uno nunca tiene la edad suficiente
para llenarle el ojo al de al lado al de
atrás al de enfrente cuando uno toma una
decisión hay que cerrar no se sesión o
que en realidad
si el de al lado toma esa decisión
va a tener los beneficios o el
sufrimiento
de 1
es decisión de nosotros
yo he decidido participar participar en
mi familia participar en mi casa en mi
empresa en mi comunidad trabajar por una
mejor sociedad hay que tener un mejor
país es responsabilidad de ustedes mía
de todos
ya no podemos dejar es quedarnos viendo
quedarnos como espectadores ya no son
los tiempos para eso eso ya pasó tenemos
que participar si queremos una mejor
ciudad un mejor estado un estado
ejemplar que nos reconozcan por nuestros
ingenieros por nuestros licenciados
no por nuestra corrupción por su
impunidad
eso nos debería dar vergüenza pero no
demos un paso atrás hay que afrontarlo
hay que participar
estos dos puntos
no tendrían sentido
si no tenemos congruencia
es muy fácil y muy bonito venir yo a
decir estoy saliendo de aquí me pase un
semáforo de una mordida de policía que
se me ponga enfrente tenemos que ser
congruentes con nuestra manera de actuar
con nuestra manera de pensar de
participar
con nuestra manera de pensar en base a
valores y principios que vayan de
acuerdo a nuestra formación a nuestra
vez a nuestra educación y no la
educación que recibimos en la escuela la
que traemos de la cuna la que recibimos
en casa
de esa de la que cada uno de ustedes y
nueve de todos los que formamos este
país estamos orgullosos
yo he trabajado mucho esta no es una
fórmula porque no estoy inventando el
hilo negro simplemente lo estoy
compartiendo lo que es algo muy sencillo
aquí el chiste es que lo hagamos
cuándo
yo amis yo tengo 30 años voy a cumplir
30 años
a mis 19 años
yo tuve un hijo
el cual ahorita tiene 10 años
estoy por estamos esperando a mi segundo
hijo una niña
y cuando hablo de participar
en una ciudad en un estado y un país
de la manera que queramos como
empresarios
como gente de la sociedad civil
es porque si nosotros no tomamos
decisiones hoy
es el futuro el que todos nos imaginamos
es el que van a vivir nuestros hijos
yo estoy
muy agradecido con este tipo de
participaciones porque hacen que la
ciudadanía salga y hable
cuando me dijeron son 18 minutos
para una persona
que lleva tiempo esperando este tipo de
eventos en una ciudad que nos hace tanta
falta la participación de todos nosotros
es suficiente
pero hay que incentivar esto hay que
motivarnos hay que ser mejores personas
hay que trabajar y trabajar y cuando
acabemos de trabajar volvamos a trabajar
no bajemos las manos depende de nosotros
depende de ti y depende de mí de cada
uno de los que estamos aquí vamos a
lograrlo no basta con quererlo hay que
hacerlo
quiero terminar más allá de una
reflexión
que con toda la gente que tengamos la
oportunidad de expresar algo un
sentimiento una experiencia una historia
un cuento lo que sea
dejemos muy claro algo
el destino de este país de ustedes de mí
de todos nosotros
no depende
no depende de nuestras condiciones
depende de nuestras decisiones de lo que
decidamos hacer de eso depende
no basta con querer
no basta nos hemos dado cuenta que no
basta con querer
depende
depende de nosotros poder
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]